reg now is the offseason Oh door is good
to be back in the house it's good to be
back in the healthier door and my dad
it's basketball season about to begin
the world series starting tonight as
well this is the best time of the year
with hockey and football yes hello hey
wrench are we on yeah yeah yeah we're on
hard I'm sure you are how are you my
friend doing great did you go anywhere
vacation doing anything interesting I
did not do anything interesting went to
Hawaii for a couple weeks to get away
with the family but that was it nice and
you're ready for best I mean all of us
could not like you know go to Brazil and
like hang out on copepoda be churning
you know fill out with all the Olympic
heroes and weren't you hanging out with
Billy Bush and I'll oh sorry no I was
not yeah I was not hanging up with him
or Ryan Lochte either and it's you are
it's too soon for that reg okay don't
you love this time of year there's to
clear it four times of the year because
you have hockey and starting basketball
starting World Series and footballs like
what seven eight weeks in this is the
best time of the year only rivaled with
March when you have baseball beginning
playoffs march madness this is this is
best the best have you been doing World
Series before I never have been to a
World Series game I want us when did my
angels win it was at 05 or 04 I can't
number if I was in Indiana watching the
World Series or was I in Malibu watching
i want to sale was in malibu by just
didn't go to the games because usually
our seasons uh I'm in training camp when
World Series is beginning but you know
you could never go your brother played
baseball in the major leagues we're
right were you a baseball family I know
you know Cheryl obviously was great you
know basketball player and so were you
but were you a baseball family oh my god
I was this follows my number one sport
growing up until I entered high school
so I always wanted to be the next to Rod
Carew so we are a huge baseball family
if you're breaking it down would
probably go basketball because that pays
the bills but baseball is like knocking
on the door in our family we were
talking about that I don't know if the
Warriors they're labeled villains but
can you really dislike the villains and
if people do why do you think people
dislike the Warriors or don't want them
to win this year I have no idea because
where did it all turn over night because
of the Kevin Durant signing this is the
most entertaining team in our league
they shoot and make threes they're fun
to watch they're all great in front of a
camera they all sit down and talk to you
so because of the Durant fighting I
think everyone liked has flipped the
script on them and don't want them to
win I love everything that steve kerr
bob myers joe lacob the owner everything
that they've done am I disappointed that
a superstar is leaving a small market
that was my only biggest criticism
because I'm looking at it from a fan
perspective because I know how much
those small market fans really live and
die with their sports teams and their
superstars so for Kevin Durant to leave
okay see that was my only problem with
it from a business standpoint it's
fabulous I mean you got I mean that's
all people are talking about is are we
going to see the trilogy obviously
there's a lot of games left to be played
seven eight months before Cleveland and
Golden State can get it on again but
I think it's great for the league how
does this not work out though starting
with Golden State how do they not win
the west well number one injuries as I
said it's a long season and even though
you have you know four all-stars two
MVPs on the same team we saw last year
when Steph was 100% and I know LeBron
can say well look two years ago I didn't
have two of my dogs with me and we got
to the finals so injuries number one and
everyone's talking about the chemistry I
don't think that'll be that big of an
issue I think as the course of the
season moves on they'll figure out a way
with moving the basketball I'm not
worried about the offensive end I'm
worried about the defensive end with
Golden State because people need to
understand how much Andrew Bogut and
Festus Ezeli meant as a rim protector
for this Golden State team step led the
league in steals last year was just over
to a game well that allowed him to
gamble a lot because when he got beat
the guy that was blocking shots and
manning the lane was Andrew Bogut and
his Ely coming off the bench they are a
much smaller team now so it's going to
be a group effort to me individual
defense is going to be huge something to
watch over the course of the year clay
and dream on our fantastic defensive
players step is good but he Gamble's a
lot and even though katie is 611 7 feet
and long arms and can block shots he's
not a great defender because he gets
overshadowed with his offense so they
become individual great defenders then
I'll be okay this is a much smaller
Golden State team reg will be calling
Spurs warriors tonight tipping off at
ten thirty eastern on tnt handicap the
rest of the West in the Clippers
obviously the Spurs whose is there a
close second at all in the West look I'm
never going to count on a team that won
67 games a year ago and Gregg Popovich
and the Spurs and obviously you're
losing you know a generational type
player in Tim Duncan but the they picked
up a pretty good guy in a surefire Hall
of Famer and Pau Gasol to kind of fill
them
and play that center spot alongside
LaMarcus Aldridge look the rains have
been tossed a quite Leonard it's his
time and again you've got one of the
best coaches of all time and Gregg
Popovich and I think this may be the
last go-round and maybe the best go
around for the Clippers it was someone
of an embarrassment how it ended last
year with the injuries and the whole
Blake Griffin you know you know punching
the equipment manager and I think they
understand that you know between Blake
and Chris Paul's they both get opt out
this summer DeAndre plane for the
Olympic team which I think was a big
boost for his ego and for his game and
Doc Rivers another great coach I think
this may be the last run those two teams
certainly can challenge golden sing but
to me its Golden State's to lose out
west Cavaliers don't make the finals if
LeBron gets hurt that's the only reason
I see the Cavs not making the NBA finals
because we already saw two years ago him
take a team to the finals really with
spotty play by Kyrie and Kevin Love both
being out with injuries and playing here
there and LeBron still got to the finals
and through the east the only way they
don't get there if LeBron misses
extended period of time or she's not a
hundred percent I think we've talked
about this before you know everybody's
got their list their top five and you
know it changes in whatever order
starting with Jordan but why is it
LeBron is not in people's top five and
sometimes begrudgingly in their top ten
what is it about him in this career that
we're still waiting for him to do where
he's anointed as one of the ten or five
greatest players of all time well number
one people are crazy be that in the top
ten the question will be top five and
you and I have had this conversation and
I came on this show and said as much as
I hate to do it when I had to take Larry
legend Larry Gilbert off my top five and
put LeBron in there I think what he did
for the city of Cleveland being down
three
and finding away in wheeling away for
them to win a championship that's why he
losing to my top five you know people
like to hold on to ghosts and I've been
one of those guys I love Michael Jordan
Magic Johnson Larry Bird I mean I grew
up in that era it's hard to let go but
people need to sit back and look at the
numbers look at the Play people six
straight now he didn't win them all six
straight NBA Finals that is so hard to
do and in this day of a with now you've
got a super team out west here with
Golden State and now the expectations
are going to be on them because to me
it's championship or bust for the
Warriors so for LeBron not to be in most
people's top five it's a little head
scratching because you've got to sit
back and appreciate the numbers well I
know that we we put Oscar Robertson in
there and I had a chance to see him play
but he won one title and if we're gonna
hold people accountable for how many
titles they have in granted he was
playing for Cincinnati got the title
when he played with Kareem abdul-jabbar
in Milwaukee to meet LeBron James has
moved past Oscar Robertson on the
all-time list and that may be
blasphemous and coming from a guy who
grew up in Cincinnati but I I think
we're holding on to the Oscar goes
because he averaged a triple-double if
he doesn't average a triple double for a
season then we're not talking about this
well again we liked to hold on to our
sports heroes and there's a lot of Oscar
Robbins and fans out there me being one
of them but you know it's time for us to
move on and look at LeBron James as one
of the greatest players our game has
ever seen people like to hold on because
of all he had to go to Miami to learn
how to win okay but he came back in 11
for Cleveland down at 31 to a team that
won 73 games that's gotta mean something
for people out there so for people that
he's not in the top ten that's crazy top
five I mean that you know it's arguable
but he's in my top five now linkers a
hard as it is to take as hard as it is
to take Larry Joe off it hurts me to do
that because that's the guy pattern my
game
rounder yeah I don't have any problem
taking Larry Joe out of the top five and
and I loved his game but I think LeBrons
had a bigger impact Laker fan should
expect what this year two or more win
more wins they had a year ago Wow I mean
they're young they're young new coach I
like Luke Walton I like to hire but
they're young well they have the same
style is gold instead even though they
don't have the same talent but is Luke
going to have that same kind of styles
Golden State I think they're going to
try and run more and they'll have a
little bit of that flex offense and
that's low options but you've got to
have the personnel if you want to play
like Golden State and they don't have a
great three-point shooting like clay or
staff and you know the playmakers of a
Kevin Durant and an all-around tool
player like draymond Green but they've
got young talent so to be interesting to
see if Randall and Russell and Ingram
those three young guys can you know
mature and grow up and find a way to
play together again i love the hire of
lukewarm but they're young and out West
where the where there's good young teams
like Utah in Minnesota that are starting
to find their way I mean those two teams
are going to be battling for the seventh
and eighth spots in my opinion out west
so they're nowhere near them so they had
a long ways ago and you're still you
would still be the best three-point
shooter on the Lakers if you were on the
roster right now I would right now I
would Luke go to out money today does
that be kept out that's your three let's
do it what if they gave you a really
nice contract for one year um david levy
can I take a sabbatical for one year and
go play for the lake and what would TNT
think if you just said I you know what
happened starting next season and you
would be what 50 52 at the time too yes
and they would fall they were promised
they don't let the door
did it hurt there's your back hurry with
the door hitting you there's a careless
certain things that never leave you and
you showed that when we were down at the
final four in Houston and you started
shooting threes and I went oh my god you
know what I'll be able to shoot till I
was 65 that's easy that's a given now if
you're asking me to move my feet
side-to-side Kawhi Leonard or any of
these guys in front of me no notes at
all right we'll have fun tonight Spurs
at the Warriors tipping off at ten
thirty eastern on tnt Reggie Allah
wishes Miller the third in his first of
many weekly appearances here thank reg
we'll talk next week Thank You Theodore
so glad to be back dad s I love you
thank you all that's Reggie Miller good
to have reg back the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience